staging a complex stunt or a giant set
piece is a massive challenge these
achievements are incredible to watch but
learning about what needed to happen
behind the scenes only makes us
appreciate them more here's a look at
some iconic movie scenes that were
nearly impossible to capture on film
Fast Five as quick-moving as its title
suggests Fast Five is at its best
during the climactic car chase through
the streets of Rio protagonist DOM and
Brian have to drag a 100 ton bank vault
behind them with the police hot on their
tail
it's such an enormous set piece that it
would be totally understandable to
assume it's mostly CGI instead it's
nearly all practical effects director
Justin Lin was adamant about using as
little CGI as possible so stunt
coordinator Jack Gill built a replica
vault that weighed 10,000 pounds
although lighter than a real metal vault
it still required souped-up cars with
oversized tires and 400 horsepower
engines so that they could actually
swing around the replicas when you're
watching DOM and Brian swing a vault
through buildings and cement like a
wrecking ball that's actually happening
somewhat surprisingly no one was hurt in
the scenes filming Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol the mission impossible
franchise has mostly become a series of
films where we watched Tom Cruise Jeep
death over and over
actually scary coolness but all other
stumps pale in comparison next to the
tower climbing sequence and Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol this sequence
Seas Cruises Ethan Hunt climbing the
exterior of the Burj Khalifa the tallest
building in the world
crews actually fired the film's
insurance company so he could perform
the climb without a stunt double with
only some rigging between him and the
ground what's more there was no way to
cushion Cruz's landing during the
climactic jump back onto the tower he
just went for it landing full force on
the glass Iron Man 3
sometimes a well performed practical
effects stunt actually looks like CGI
because of how impossible it seems case
in point the breathtaking airplane
rescue set piece from Iron Man 3
remember that game called barrel of
monkeys that's a rarity of 18,000
people everybody grab me monkey in order
to shoot the scene without CGI the
filmmakers began with two days of
testing at the airport to make sure it
could even work once they determined it
was possible they proceeded to make the
jump multiple times a day all alongside
a cameraman days to shoot it we ended up
making 62 airplane loads over 600
parachute jumps 480 some hidden
parachute jumps the extra effort of
using practical effects resulted in a
genuinely thrilling action sequence
cliffhanger 1993's cliffhanger is a
perfect example of a dangerous stunt
making a movie a classic one
jaw-dropping scene involves a character
traveling from one airplane to another
via a single cable the planes had to
travel at an exact speed of 150 miles
per hour each if either sped up stuntman
Simon Crain could have been ripped in
half
any faster and the force of the wind
would likely pull cranes limbs from his
torso the altitude and wind created
numbing temperatures as well with crane
having to dawn a special prosthetic
facemask in order to endure the cold
luckily cream managed to perform the
stunt almost perfectly except for some
trouble getting pulled into the second
plane the door
bounce bounce again and that's when I
hit went above and slid along the roof
cranes death-defying stunt is as
breathtaking now as it was when the film
first came out Ben Hur shooting a
biblical drama in the 1950s offered very
little room for cinematic sleight of
hand and 1959's Ben Hur was no different
the famous chariot race took nearly a
year to prepare with the million dollar
arena set carved out of a quarry by a
thousand workmen among other intense
preparations I went over
the shoot itself required nearly a
hundred trained racehorses that actually
ended up being faster than the car
carrying the camera
this gave the cameramen only a few
seconds to get each shot per take even
with a head start in addition the heat
limited the horses to eight runs a day
and a stunt gone wrong
very nearly resulted in stuntman joka
nut being trampled by his horses and
chariots
despite everything the filmmakers and
crew managed to pull the whole thing off
for that alone they deserved all 11 of
the Oscars the film received Raiders of
the Lost Ark Indiana Jones and the
Raiders of the Lost Ark is chock-full of
some of the most memorable imagery in
film history one particularly famous
stunt proved more difficult than others
the sequence in which Harrison Ford's
stuntman Terry Leonard is dragged along
a dirt road behind a speeding truck
despite the fact that Leonard only
drifts under the truck for six seconds
the stunt was immensely dangerous thank
belief Leonard came away unscathed
pulling off one of the greatest stunts
of all time
[Music]